hello Munich it's my first time here and
I'm really excited to talk to all of you
so I am Keerthana Krishnan I'm coming
all the way from India and I'd like to
talk to you about my experience with
handling the front-end and web
architecture about today what happens is
that our product was created eight years
ago and then a few years later in about
2017 our team found out new motors have
come into the marketplace
after we started a product so our
customers are demanding you need to add
this add additional feature you need to
add this entire new set of features and
we decided that in our current monolith
framework this it's not possible to add
the many more so necessarily pushed us
and with that we had to we had to find
creative ways to add these features so
we experimented with web architectures
and I am here to tell you about the
results for that the pros and cons and
some great use cases that we found from
trial and error so that you don't have
to go through them let the case match
between the architectures begin consider
a use case now as you can see this is
not oil software this is Amazon you
might be confused for a minute by all
this stuff happening but it's still
Amazon so due to an NDA I cannot show
you my code I cannot even think of my
code right now so let's let's find
something almost as complex if not more
complex trust me via more complex Amazon
so this UI I hope nobody works for
Amazon here because I am going to call
it ugly it has a drop down over there a
list of recommendation ads on top ads on
the side a search bar another drop down
user details so many things happening in
this one small UI you were not call it
clean the screen is full of beta because
when we ask them do you want us to give
you a beautiful minimalist UI with react
they are like what is this react don't
show me all the data I want to monitor
ROI right so that's the kind of use case
I deal with so what was it what
my application look like so all model is
in general now we are using Amazon here
Amazon they have logical you and it's
structured inside them so when you when
your code starts out its life nobody
starts out as a micro service starts out
as one single unit so in Amazon's case
probably has items it needs to sell its
users the users rating their items
vendors adds all that thing is bundled
into one single unit right that's a
monolith now in the future when Amazon
divided it up how did their micro
services probably look like let's
venture a guess so
items probably at their own logical unit
users probably have their own logical
units all those logical components which
interact independently from each other
probably got a micro service of its own
so this is just to help you visualize
how an ideal of web architecture is
going to look like what happens when we
when we turn this down into a server
less architecture in server lists we
further subdivide it so if you think of
the user as a logical component on its
own in server lists
adding a user simply that functionality
is by itself one function so you add
that to the server less server with
which Amazon hosts in a secret undefined
location and you just put a function
call to that so all of your entire logic
is subdivided into these simple pure
functions which you can call and it just
runs somewhere so that's how services in
the beginning and I got a pro tip from
one of the speakers yesterday I had a
cat pick free laughs from the audience
so that's your cat pick so in the
beginning your code base is small it's
cute you remember the file names you can
think of the edge cases like and I had
this divided by 0 will happen yeah
that's probably the only edge case and
you can think of it that's it's small
its cuddly what happens you add another
features you add another feature
something breaks in production and you
put a band-aid somewhere something else
breaks and then it's held together by
prayers a few more features a few more
years later
this is what happens when you die that's
what that cat becomes when you tried to
change anything in production
trust me this has happened to us not the
tiger but still Tiger would have been
better trust me
so in a real-life scenario our
application has been running for eight
plus years now this is a product that
generates a multi-million dollar revenue
right we can't just simply change one
part of it our company would fire all of
us it's written with javascript in Java
after eight years let me tell you most
of the people who wrote some of the
orders inner functionality are no longer
with us
I can feel somebody like oh god the pain
you feel so this is our team last year
that's Alice falling into the rabbit
hole for those who got it and we decided
nope
our customers won't this functionality
by hook or by crook we are going to get
this done I would not recommend that you
break up a monolith from hindsight my
team lead would not recommend that you
break up a monolith you know if we had
thought of it clearly well enough he
would have thought if we needed to add
the new features we would have just
taken three months more and build
another application that would have been
easier that would have been better but
no we took the first step we were
enchanted by the rabbit we looked at the
rabbit hole and we thought does anyone
feat it can do this he could not do this
so what did we do we're not crazy people
we did not one day decide to break up a
monolith we are smart people who decided
to do a proof of concept one small proof
of concept for a microt service and
another one for service and as proof of
concepts go they worked out pretty well
because they're small small kitten again
I deliver so when the small POC works
what's the next step
the proof of concept worked so this has
to work so we we report to a product
owner so we told him yeah the the proof
concept worked so he he took out his
calculator like we have 40 and
yes we have 10,000 files yeah we can
visit for months we can convert the
entire monolith into a bunch of
serverless function for months it's
always you take our tech lead he was a
bit more careful he said give us six
months six months done make it your
entire code base serverless it took
where more than six months in fact it's
still happening initially when I applied
for the CFP this six months it was still
happening it was in the honeymoon months
so I thought we will convert all of that
into service I'll give you my honest to
god feedback about how service is
amazing and we now have a missing
application but we understood the truth
is not as things broke and service is
not always the Silver Bullet function
that you think it is so there are still
parts of our monolith left and that
pipeline was built about one year into
our application and every single person
who wrote that application or that part
of our code left and that is not
something we were able to change so our
code looks like this that is the
pipeline that we cannot touch as we
create a newer micro service it just
takes a bit of the blood out of our
application like a bunch of vampire wet
micro services exists but the more blood
we take out of this that Frankenstein
monster still lives we cannot kill it
stake does not kill it sun rays do not
kill it this that Frankenstein does not
die that's our monolith so microservices
back best practices so we found out no
serverless is out of the question and I
will tell you why later
but microservices if you have to build
them start fresh right if you have an
existing application that you want to
break get your knowledge from it see how
your code is made in that take a few
extra months I'd say start building the
code ground up and add more micro
services as you begin I am NOT saying
that it's difficult to add a Microsoft
System or monolith but the overall code
complexity and the way in which you have
to figure out so many
things and the rule of thumb is the more
years your software has been in
production the more your complexity is
higher and the more it will be difficult
to break up your monolith right so from
Microsoft's point of view you you get
more control in your implementation if
you have large data heavy applications
like Asus for example as is clearly
having a lot of data coming in real-time
data coming in for those kind of
applications micro-services are
definitely better it helps you handle
all those large complex problems that
you can't solve in a single malfunction
it gives you control and security I'll
come to security in a minute and you can
customize your micro service going back
to our use case of Amazon for for a
second again because I can't use my
business logic to illustrate this point
imagine a user of Amazon now in the
future if amp now Amazon you can follow
another user I think you can follow
authors if you follow books in the
future they might add a few more
features for users you know maybe you
can follow a vendor to see if they bring
up any new products or you can follow a
particular product to see when it's
available next all those functionalities
are being done by the user so if you
have a functionality done by a user a
single function of the user which
triggers another function for another
component all those interplay of logic
is much better handled when you have a
micro service rather than when you have
a server less application that's
something we learned the hard way so
when a serval is a good choice good
question it's more efficient for smaller
pieces of logic so again rule of thumb
the more beautiful your UI is the more
minimalist the UI is serverless is
better suited for you so if you're
starting an application tomorrow hey I
want to create an application I'm going
to see what are the best places to eat
in an around Munich right that good way
should not be so hard to manage that
should be a very small codebase or
depending on the features that you add
to it it's it's a user facing
functionality things like those
serverless will work pretty well but
tomorrow if you're gonna start right in
your own oil and gas monitoring
application your own vendor marketplace
your own application that takes so much
of data and then processes it then
serverless might not be your first
choice it will not be my recommended
choice but service is scalable it's easy
to change the function to fit
requirements show of hands how many
people over here the second last day of
your sprint your technique has come to
you and said the client wants one small
change in that UI you've built today one
small change
show of hands a lot of people have been
hit by that arrow in the chest I see
that so those kind of problems service
is a good antidote right you can change
it very easily and you can see your
changes very easily
serverless is at work there and for UI
in terms of applications for
applications that use UI a lot for
example if you use it
internationalization localization
progressive web apps for example that's
a good use case for server applications
because it's UI intensive but data
intensive applications do not I would
not recommend service maybe in a few
years
serverless will become much better
adapted to handle larger amounts of data
maybe we'll figure it out a way but in
the current implementation server less
is not something I would recommend again
no no no the services UI is crowded nope
data and computation heavy scenarios no
and data security is something I'd
talked about earlier so in our
application we have a small problem that
you probably will never face we handle a
lot of data which is not us oil and gas
data is very sensitive so the manager
from Saudi Arabia definitely says things
like I'll give you one server it would
be in Riyadh
you can sit three engineers to set it up
no data goes out of the walls of Saudi
Arabia serverless will not work for that
I'm very sorry you have no idea where
your servant
server officer Ellis's hosted so for all
those applications where your data
should be controlled sensitivity of data
security of data sure Amazon has some
agreements that you can sign but can you
really trust them I'm not I'm not
hitting on Amazon here I mean I like it
I use your products please don't lie to
me but still and the same is the case
for Microsoft as well I'm not competing
with just Amazon all of the service
providers this is this is a valid
criticism and like I said earlier the
function to function calls are again
pretty brutal so calling functions in
service functions inside micro services
I'm sure a few of you have thought this
right now if service micro services can
handle complex stuff and service can
handle function calls how about I wrap
all the complex stuff of one logical
unit inside a micro service and I call a
service inside that genius right right
no don't do that so what happens and I
speak this because we actually try doing
this I'm not proud to admit that but we
actually did do this and what happens is
that all the negative ions of micro
services all the negative finds a
service is come together and you you you
lose your sleep for one week before you
give up and you decide to go for either
one of the architectures and we went for
Mike to services but don't don't combine
this no and one more thing that you
should be very careful of is that when
you choose your micro service make sure
your micro service is not a monolith in
disguise that's one point it's wrong as
a Pvt but I forgot to hide that but it's
it's similar to it's the same point of
mismatch in your web architectures right
so if your micro service if you're
choosing a micro service make sure that
you choose it as a logical unit whatever
you do scalability starts at design
design is where you decide which what is
your logical unit
for example their Amazon might not have
the exact breakup that I mentioned maybe
users is not a unit at all you know it's
just ratings vendors ads all that stuff
but whatever you do make sure that in
the early step of your design you design
it in a way that in the future you think
you'll add more features even if your
genre doesn't sure no my application is
perfect
no more features can be added to this
pristine beauty still write it in a
scalable way come on it's a it's a it's
a it's good thing for your future self
and documenting your functions is
something else that it's so criminally
underrated especially as engineers we do
this we write a function it works
so the I've seen documentation in my own
company called well the documentation
for a function is backslash backslash it
works so point so please say about your
function name is you know have have a
system to record it and where this
definitely is a becomes a pinch point is
imagine that you implemented your server
list architecture all of your functions
are now serval is it's done by a few
engineers two years down the line
they've they have left your company to
more news your engineers join and now
they have to understand what this
hellscape of function calls is there is
no documentation and that situation
there will either be a riot or two more
people will click with your company
either one of those will happen so
document your code and good quality code
and good quality code there are a lot of
parameters he'll go into good quality
cold and I really don't have time in to
get into all of us know this all of us
can google this so good quality code is
definitely an investment for your
products future in summary a monolith
unless existing in legacy code and not
for commercial applications it's not
recommended but let's be honest here
every single application starts out as a
monolith you know every single thing
will start out as a monolith that's very
my previous comment learning
come into picture sorry when you start
out as a monolith you know make sure you
design it in such a way that in the
future you can add more things in
micro-services for example you can
divide and conquer a larger and complex
requirement to small individual units
serverless again things become much more
abstracted it's best for smaller modular
use cases so that's my time here today I
really loved having all of you and I'd
like to give a huge thanks the
organizers my wonderful interpreter and
most definitely my team for helping me
come here and present to all of you I
will still be around until the end of
this conference so if anybody has doubts
about web architecture please do come
and catch me and these are some of the
references are used especially giffy big
shout-out to Givi and this is me you can
find me into it as well thank you
[Applause]
[Music]